you just clicked on this video and
you're probably thinking that fixing
Game of Thrones season 8 is an
impossible task but hey I'll try my damn
best after making fun of it for over a
year an easy solution would be to just
say do more seasons 4head but that would
be too easy it would make for a boring
video so instead I'll try to fix and
come up with better alternatives for the
biggest mistakes that occurred in season
8 I obviously won't be able to fix
everything in this video so if you guys
like it I'll definitely make a part 2 so
the first question is what are the main
problems with the season that piss
people off the most to me the most
infuriating issues are how they handle
the night king in the long night the
execution of the mad Queen's storyline
and the show's ending so first let's
look at the night king one of the
glaring issues with the execution of the
night king is that he was killed by Arya
Stark the reason why it's an issue is
that she has never interacted with the
night King or White Walkers before this
is like having Jon Snow kill Cersei it
would feel weird because he's never
really had a personal interaction with
her nor does he have any personal
dynamic with her he can't have a
character in a long-lasting series that
has never seen or interacted with a
character before suddenly making it
their own personal goal to kill them
like sure some characters that Arya
likes are being threatened by the night
King but since she does not have any
ties with him it wouldn't have that much
payoff for Arya to kill him so instead
it would make sense for her to just help
out in the fight to protect the ones she
loves Arya is a part of an entirely
different subplot that has its own
antagonists these are the antagonist
that were set up for this particular
character so does eating her into Jon
Snow subplot and having her take on the
antagonist that she owes never seen it's
just bad writing so the question is how
do you fix the handling of the night
king in the long night to me there are
only two ways you can have a satisfying
outcome either you go the epic way of
having Jon Snow take on the night king
and the heroes win or you have a twist
in which the heroes lose Winterfell in a
hardhome style episode and they have to
overcome the night king in a way that
the audience cannot predict I like the
second option more
I think it would have been a good fit to
an episode too with the invasion of
Winterfell that lasts like 20 to 30
minutes episode 2 is pretty good but not
much really happens because it's just
characters talking the whole time it
would have been a good change of pace
for that episode that end in action
because of how slow it was if you have
only six episodes something needs to
happen story wise in those episodes or
you'll have to cram in the remaining
ones which is what they did so going
back to the long night battle after the
Dothraki fall in a mere 30 seconds
Daenerys would probably give the order
to evacuate since they are in a losing
situation at that point also to create
an even bigger sense of hopelessness you
can sprinkle in the death of some of the
best fighters like rearm and torment you
can also have them die to a wave of
white walkers that fight them on the
battlefield in addition I would
definitely make would be to add a
[ __ ] moon that lights the battlefield
because you can't see shits it's
honestly just baffling how unpleasant it
is to watch because of how dark it is I
would also add more red priests helping
out during the fight since the Lord of
Light supports the living it doesn't
make sense for him to just send one red
priestess you can have a lot of them die
and have Melisandre fall in battle
instead of having her turn into the
embodiment of season 8 so those would be
some of the additions that I think would
make the actual Battle of Winterfell
much more enjoyable turn it into a harem
style episode and include the quality of
life improvements the reason why you
don't want the heroes to win in this
episode is because of how anti-climatic
it would feel the night king and the
White Walkers have been set up since the
beginning of the show and ending that
whole build-up in one episode does not
feel right the long night just ends up
being a couple hours and this massive
threat ends up having no impact on the
overall story so to make it have an
impact on the overall story you need to
have the night king threaten everyone on
the board instead of just the north
because currently you can just remove
the right Walker's from season 8 and
nothing would really change
I'm going to go now they were just used
to make the nurses army weaker
how far good so my initial pitch after
the heroes evacuate from Winterfell and
it gets destroyed would be to stop the
night king at all costs before he gets
to King's Landing the stakes would be
much higher because we know that
Westeros in its entirety would fall
because of the millions of people that
live in King's Landing and that would
feel the night king's army how many
people live in million give or take
small people than the entire north
crammed into that either everyone will
be forced to work together or we would
finally see the night King take a seat
on the Iron Throne just any form of
higher stakes or greater impact from the
long night would be better than what we
got given Circe's past history she would
probably be stubborn and would pay the
price we would also get the benefit of
giving Cersei more things to do all she
did was stare out windows and if we
throw the obstacle of the night king at
her then her swore line could be more
interesting so that would be my solve to
the long night and night king issue
another big issue would be the handling
of the mad queen in this video I will
keep the mad Queen arc but I'll try to
fix the execution of it when Daenerys
snapped it didn't seem very motivated
all she did was just stare at the Red
Keep and then she suddenly lost her mind
what would make more sense would be to
have an event that would make her lose
it I would say the easiest event would
be instead of killing ragel in episode 4
have him die in episode 5 this would fix
two problems on one hand you have one of
the most stupid deaths in the history of
the show
this death was literally just played for
shock value and doesn't make sense
because while Dany kind of forgot about
the iron fleet and Euron's forces they
certainly haven't forgotten about her on
top of the stupid death we don't have
any time to mourn the death of regal the
death of a Syrian was so much better
because it had active set up and we saw
the reaction of characters that loved
him
the difference with this scene is that
we had no set up in a miniscule reaction
from Daenerys so you can just have this
battle to retake Dragonstone and in the
process the nurses fleet takes a big hit
and they lose mass on day that's fine
they don't need to kill raiga on the
scene and it would make more sense for
our girl to get taken down by the dozens
of scorpions in King's Landing
it could be as simple as instead of
Daenerys looking at the Red Keep and
losing her mind she is looking at ray
galls dead corpse it could be the final
scorpion shot thigh gets the last shot
off and Pierce's Rygel's neck and the
nurse has to watch her child slowly
bleed out she is the closest to her
dragons because they are her children
losing one and letting that moment
marinate would be very emotional instead
of this hollow reaction of the nurse
losing her [ __ ] for no reason
with this new motivation it would make
more sense for Daenerys to destroy
King's Landing from her new enragement
another option for the destruction of
King's Landing would either beat Cersei
detonating most of the wildfire or my
last pitch the night king would end up
getting down south and there'll be a
battle for King's Landing really any
option would be better than what David
and den ended up going with so looking
at the last issue I said in the
beginning of the video is that the
ending is pretty abysmal one of the most
important lines of the show that teased
the ending was how Daenerys wants to
break the wheel Lannister Targaryen
Baratheon stark Tyrell they're all just
spokes on a wheel
it's ones on tops and that one's on top
and on and on it spins crushing those on
the ground which the wheel represented
the constant rotation of power and how
many people will get crushed by it the
problem with the ending is that Daenerys
goes against this and literally just
becomes a tyrant and adds to the problem
of the wheel she goes against her very
goal and it feels like they compromise
this in the pursuit of making her the
mad Queen it's also ironic that drogon
knew what breaking the wheel men more
than what Daenerys did the iron throne
is the embodiment of the wheel this
constant pursuit of power causes most of
the conflict in the show
just because you get rid of the yarn
thrown that doesn't mean you fix the
problem they so elect a leader to roll
over Westeros and this will always
create a future conflict for people
wanting to be in that position yes they
are elected from a committee but you can
so manipulate the people voting and
threaten and do many horrible things to
get votes to me the main solution would
have been independence for each of the
Seven Kingdoms the North wanted their
independence and so did the Iron Islands
but they just kind of forgot about that
so and a better alternative scene we can
have the North claimed independence
followed by the Iron Islands and then
this would cause a chain reaction of the
rest of the kingdoms warning their
independence it would still be an epic
moment of having each leader stand up
one by one claiming their independence
this would remove what the Iron Throne
stood for there would no longer be a
source of conflict for a position with
more power since every Kingdom would be
equal this would break the wheel instead
of making bran the new king choosing a
king off of a good story is a trash
weigh in determining the future of
Westeros and on top of that they choose
the most boring character who wasn't
even in season five and sat around and
did nothing but yeah actually breaking
the wheel at the end of the show having
a more satisfying conclusion for the
long night and fixing the execution of
the Mad Queen would have made season 8
so much better there are obviously still
a lot more issues that I can go into and
if this video does well then I would be
glad to make more thank you guys for
watching and have a nice day